Babycore, thanks for the gift dude!
Hello everybody!
Hold on, I gotta turn on my fan.
It's kinda hot in here.
It's hot because I'm ready to make... Oh no, wait.
Hold on, I forgot something.
Some hot deal!
I had my glasses on the whole time.
I thought that I forgot.
Whoopsie.
I thought I forgot my glasses.
But I had them on my head the whole time.
Anyway, I am so sick of listening to this music.
Hold on, Babycore, thank you for the 5 more gifted.
Thank you!
Arisa, thanks for the super chat.
And I saw someone else.
I think it was you, Sprank.
Am I right?
Oh my gosh.
Yes!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you so much!
I recognize your cat.
Bald or no bald?
Gosh, there we go.
Start.
Bald, of course.
That's how Howie would want it.
Right, Mr. Mando?
Yeah.
I know I'm kinda big right now, but don't worry, I'll get smaller.
Andricos, thanks for the time gift dude!
Are you ready for some of the most disturbing models in the history of Wii shovelware?
Molotov by Iron Shepherd Wii?
Okay, so I have seen...
Because I tested this.
Hello?
I have seen the very soulless, scary models that stand in the background of this game.
It's quite something to view.
I am so ready.
Oh my god, I am so ready to make some money, baby!
I'm so ready!
Or lose all my money.
Who knows?
I actually don't know how this game works.
Deal... or no deal.
So, look at this.
Also, this has like custom games, so I think you can rig it.
Play a game of Deal or No Deal with custom settings of your choosing.
You can rig the game!
Game on!
Can I get a happy birthday?
For...
Garfield.
This is Garfield's birthday today, you guys.
This is why we are playing Deal or No Deal.
Look, there's challenges.
Series of games with specific goals that test your luck, skill, and endurance.
Mini-games that are fast and fun.
You can play against the computer or some friends.
And extras.
Oh, oh, never mind.
Extras is nothing.
It's just the credits.
Why would you put it under extras then?
What's under the mini-games?
Push your luck.
Play a game of chance to win some fast cash.
Sharp shooter.
Test your shooting skills in this fun game.
FBA.
Blackjack!
They have Blackjack.
Try your hand at good old 21.
Deal or No Deal style.
Literally eating veggies lasagna.
Gamble, gamble, marathon.
Play all three mini-games in a row against friends or the AI.
GW.
And leaderboard.
We'll try these later, right?
Minto, you ready to see those hot babes?
Oh, you know it.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so ready.
I'm so ready to see some hot babes.
All in on Minto.
Okay.
TV show style though.
Okay, so...
I don't know Deal or No Deal that well.
I think it's... okay.
You open up some boxes.
And they have money inside.
And then there's a banker guy who's like, I'm gonna offer you some money.
I think.
Or something.
I don't actually quite know.
You pick a box and hope it's a big number.
No, don't you hope it's a small number?
Aren't you trying to eliminate the small numbers and then you get the big numbers from the bank?
Can I buy a vowel?
Oh, I have a Mii that I created.
I wonder if you can tell.
Which one is mine.
Okay.
If you delete this Mii from the Mii Channel, you will not delete this profile.
You will be assigned a default character.
Cool.
I also...
It's really hard to move on this... on the Wii.
I kind of got his name wrong.
So...
I have really shaky hands.
I was trying to write it out.
Hopefully that doesn't mess me up in this... in the future.
Play a game of Deal or No Deal where you're trying to pick the case with the million dollars or walk out with as much money as possible.
Play it over a series of rounds.
Remove cases...
Oh, it totally explains it.
Remove cases until the banker makes an offer for your case.
Accept the offer and go home.
Or keep playing to try and win even more.
Special events such as the Million Dollar Mission can help you win even more money.
So have some fun trying to beat the banker.
We're gonna beat his butt.
The sad thing is that the eyebrows are not united.
It wouldn't let me if I tried.
I tried.
It's knowledge snared.
Howie!
Welcome to Deal or No Deal.
I'm Howie Mandel.
Ladies, please.
Where did the music go?
Oh my God, here they come.
Wow!
Holy mo...
Oh, wow.
Oh, God.
Not a single one of them is blinking.
Ladies, please.
Ladies, please back up.
Oh, God.
So scarily.
Hello, ladies.
Hi.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
Skinny Snake.
Hi, Howie.
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money.
The soulless people in the background.
We don't know what's in what case.
But we do know one case is holding one million dollars.
Sorry if the audio is like so weird.
It's loud and then it's not loud.
Hi, Howie.
Howie.
Oh, take a vote.
I get to pick a case.
Okay, guys.
Time to pick a case.
Now in my brain, I'm thinking 4, 14, or 24.
But also, maybe we should pick it by how...
I mean, they're all really sexy, so it's hard to say, right?
Four?
Pick number four.
26.
No, I think that's bad luck to pick the very last case, right?
Three.
Pick number three, my lord.
Four.
Okay.
A lot of people saying four.
Ten.
Oh, I'm nervous.
Okay.
I'm gonna go with four.
I'm gonna go with my gut.
You.
Oh.
Kayla.
That's your case to keep, to take home, to spend, do whatever you want to do.
Do whatever you want, unless you should decide to sell it.
Let's find out if you got a million dollars in there.
You ready?
Let's start by opening up six cases.
Five gifted.
Okay.
So we're opening six cases.
All right.
What's our first case?
I can't believe we got Kayla.
Happy Pride, everybody.
Oh my goodness.
What could be the first case we go with?
This girl kind of looks like me though, right?
Maybe I should start with her.
I got to knock out.
I got to knock her out.
She kind of looks like me.
Kayla and Icon.
Did her parents hate her?
12?
Okay.
I see someone said 12.
Where is 12?
Right here.
I'm taking number 12 out.
Why is Snake looking...
Open the case.
Oh no.
Why are you cheering?
That's a lot of money.
Oh.
Okay.
You have to open up five more cases.
Okay, five more cases, guys.
But it's not a million.
Okay, we want the million to be in number four, the one that we grabbed.
Right?
I love the dance.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I'm nervous.
22.
I don't know about you.
I'm feeling 22.
Yeah.
Open the case.
Five dollars!
Happy!
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
The audience, everything.
I think, I feel like we are literally in the Twilight Zone right now.
Him silently jumping.
Okay, guys, next one.
It's gotta be seven?
I'm thinking 16!
I don't know!
I'm gonna take out 16.
Okay, hold on, I lost the Wii.
Hold on.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
16.
I'm taking out 16.
If I can press it.
Okay.
Go with your gut.
Melanie!
Please, open the case.
Open the case.
Oh!
Not bad.
It could be worse.
Okay, three cases left, though.
Three cases left, you guys.
Okay, come on.
Seven?
Seven!
I saw seven first.
I'm gonna go with seven.
Come on, come on.
That's bad.
No, it's fine.
If seven is even higher, I'm gonna scream.
Twenty-five!
Yippee!
Do a dance, Snake.
Oh, never mind.
Just gonna stand there.
A heretic!
Happy birthday!
Two cases left open.
Two?
Who is breathing?
Do you guys hear someone breathing?
They're like...
Ten?
Thirteen?
I see ten.
Ten is one of the ones that you guys wanted me to pick, so...
Something very uncanny about this.
Open the case.
Snake, you gotta look in the direction.
One cent!
You guys wanted me to pick this fucking box!
Are you kidding me?
You guys were trying to jinx me!
It's literally the lowest number!
You guys wanted me to go home with nothing!
Okay, last case, you guys.
Last case.
Nineteen!
She's cute.
I promise you the answer is eighteen.
Oh, sorry, Michi.
She's cute, though.
Wait, what was her name?
Jian!
Five thousand?
They're happy about that.
The crowd is pleased.
They will not eat us yet.
Okay, what's happening now?
Not too bad.
There's a man in this room with just one job.
And it's a nasty job.
And his job is to get you out of here for as little as possible.
Why is Howie so small?
He's looking at the board, he's looking at you, and he wants to buy that case for as little as possible.
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
The banker?
He's gonna call me and make you an offer right now.
I see him up there.
What do you think is gonna happen?
I don't know!
I don't know, Howie!
Hello.
Okay.
Yeah?
What's the offer?
Right.
He looks like the...
Villain and Detective Conan.
The new offer?
Oh!
63,000!
Deal or no deal?
Oh!
He said the thing!
Deal... or no deal?
I think no deal.
That's a terrible offer.
Terrible offer.
They're only allowed to blink once they open a case.
Till then, only constant solo stares.
Deal or no deal?
No deal.
No deal!
I believe in my case.
He's pondering.
He doesn't know what to do.
No deal!
I was gonna say nobody cared about that, I guess.
Five cases to open.
Why does this sound like I'm in a serial killer?
Like...
It sounds like I'm in a thriller show.
Okay, um, I know Michi said 18, so I'm gonna go with that.
I'm seeing some people say one.
I'll go with that next.
18?
Michelle?
Open the case.
Don't let me down.
$50!
Nice, nice, nice!
Okay.
Four cases.
I'm gonna go with one.
Numero uno, everybody.
Numero uno.
If I can click it.
You.
Open the case.
Okay!
$10,000.
That's like... that's like...
That's less than what was our offer, though.
So we're still okay, I think.
Right?
Not bad.
It's okay.
We're trying to get the left column.
Okay, three cases left open.
You guys, I'm sweating so bad.
Oh, my God.
You're me trying to win an Oscar or something.
Five?
Okay, I'm seeing five.
Unlucky.
Who is breathing?
Open the case.
Oh, my God.
No!
Five was bad!
Camille!
Oof.
Not good.
Two cases left open.
Okay.
Eight.
Twenty-three.
We haven't got any up here, really.
Just a few.
Let's do twenty-three.
Twenty-three.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna save eleven for last.
She's just gonna stand in there in the middle.
Please, open the case.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Snake's like, come on.
Ugh!
Don't clap, everyone!
Teresa, no!
No!
Oh, my God.
One more case.
I think I'm gonna single out eleven as much as possible.
Let's go to seventeen, I think.
I'm gonna go to seventeen.
I'm trusting my gut.
Thirteen is totally a lucky number.
Okay, fine.
I'll get thirteen out of the way.
You guys tell me.
Tell me if it's good or not.
Tell me.
Open the case.
Tell me what the damage is.
Do I got it, Doc?
Is it terminal?
Ten dollars!
Yippee!
They're all, like, clapping in sync.
What do you think's gonna happen?
I don't know, Howie.
I don't know.
Hello.
Okay.
Moshi moshi.
Really?
Okay.
What do you mean, really?
The people in the audience are so...
The offer did go.
It went up!
Deal or no deal?
You guys, this is pretty good.
Eighty-three thousand dollars.
That's pretty good.
No deal?
We want at least a hundred K.
You know what?
You're so right.
No deal!
Why is Howie the most realistic looking...
What if I have the one million?
Okay, four cases.
My lucky number.
For some reason, my eyes went to nine first.
Fourteen?
My lucky number?
My second lucky number?
Twenty-one?
Blackjack?
All or nothing?
Oh, gosh.
I don't know.
Twenty-one?
Hmm.
You.
Open the case.
Karen?
Gosh,
we have so many, like, hundred, two hundred.
We have so many.
I'm not listening to you guys ever again.
I'm going with nine.
It's my gut.
Baka baka.
Emily!
Please, open the case.
Emily, I believe in you.
Three hundred!
Nice.
Thank you.
The what with the goatee?
Two cases left over.
Also, Zachary, sorry I saw your stream live just now.
Thanks for getting the Minta Matara merch.
I love it.
Your standees are on my bookshelf.
I have a bag to carry my stuff walking home from work.
Yippee!
Thank you.
Twenty-six is free?
Okay.
I'm seeing several twenty-sixes.
Twenty-five.
I'm going to close my eyes and pick one.
I don't know which one I just did.
Twenty-five!
Open the case.
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
One more case.
Don't open twenty.
Why?
You're making me want to open.
Eleven is sus.
You know what?
I'm going to knock eleven out.
I'm going to get rid of this.
There's going to be a big old gap in the middle.
Get out of here, eleven.
Open the case.
It was sus in a bad way.
Here comes the offer.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Hello.
Let's see.
The Future Mints case has one dollar.
No, it doesn't.
Okay.
Freak Phantom.
A new offer?
Oh!
Close, but no cigar.
Deal or no deal?
Deal?
Take the deal, Mints.
No!
It's not six figures yet.
It's so close.
But I'm going to have to pay taxes on that.
No deal.
Okay.
I believe in my case.
Why does he just...
He doesn't do anything.
Okay.
Three cases left.
Don't give Mints money?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
That banker looked like a boss, baby.
Three?
Pick number three, my lord.
I'm Shari K.
Open the case.
Oh!
Okay.
Could be worse.
Oh gosh, there's a whole lot of blanked out numbers on the right side.
There's a whole lot of...
Two cases left open.
You guys!
I'm scared.
I was thinking eight.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Audra.
Don't let me down.
Audra!
Yes, Audra!
I was gonna say, you're too hot to let me down.
There's still one dollar up on the board.
Uh-oh.
But also one million dollars.
One case.
I can...
I feel the knife that Howie...
It's off screen, but he's like holding it up to my neck right now, you know?
Why are you guys trying to jinx me?
You're aiming to win a dollar, right?
Stop!
Oh my gosh.
Two...
Six?
Oh, six is down here in the corner.
Barely even...
It's just...
It's hiding away, you know?
Six!
Hannah.
I should have left you in the corner.
Hannah, what are you doing to me?
Okay, Barn, thank you.
Remember an episode of the actual show where a guy's wife forced him to take the deal and then it turned out he had the million?
Hello.
Oh, okay.
That doesn't sound good.
Oh.
It sounds bad.
The offer's gonna be so low.
It's gonna be so bad.
The offer did go.
It went up!
Oh, okay.
Deal or no deal?
Deal.
You guys?
I wanna believe in my case.
I wanna believe in my case!
I want to believe in the four!
Believe in the four!
I want...
I...
You know what?
I think we have the one million.
We have the one million.
Deal.
No deal!
There's still a million dollars!
Two cases left over.
Spitters, exactly.
You have the one dollar.
No I don't!
Twenty-four?
Twenty-six?
Twenty?
Let's go with twenty-six.
You over there, Elizabeth.
Nice!
Guys, we might win this.
One more case.
Seventeen?
Fifteen?
Twenty-four?
I'm seeing a lot of fifteens.
You guys don't let me down.
Come on, snag the stairs.
Amy!
Please, open the case.
What is this angle?
Okay!
We're clapping.
We're stoic clapping.
We have three numbers on each side.
I think our offer is going to go up.
Hello.
Okay.
I'll tell him.
Alright.
Love you too.
Okay.
A new offer?
It barely went up!
Deal or no deal?
Banker looking desperate.
You don't think he ever says that too?
Like, thanks mom.
This dream is going to turn my feathers white.
No deal.
No deal, you guys.
Come on.
I'm not a sucker.
I'm no sucker.
No deal.
One more case.
Just one?
Seventeen.
Right smack dab in the middle.
Please, open the case.
Open the case.
You guys, I think we have a dollar.
You guys, I think we have just one dollar.
Oh my god.
Here comes the offer.
It's going to go up.
Look at these soulless people.
They're ready to eat my body.
Okay.
They're ready to bum rush the stage.
They're ready to tear me limb from limb.
Especially that guy over there.
It went up.
It went up a hole.
Oh my god.
The banker is like literally molding the room.
The banker is cursing me out right now.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I want to take it but I don't.
In real life, I would take that.
Yeah, but this is a video game.
Look at him.
I want to see him still be salty.
Get your dollar.
I think the person who said they were from the future's name.
No deal.
He's like, what's wrong with you?
What's wrong with you, Solid Sturge?
One case.
He's rage quitting.
24 or 2?
A lot of people saying 2.
A lot of people saying 24.
I'm going to go with 2.
I can't look.
Open the case.
Uh-oh.
Hey, banker.
Banker.
We can talk this out.
Okay.
Banker.
He's laughing.
Okay.
He's laughing at me.
No way.
I went down.
There's no way I have the dollar.
Deal?
No deal.
I think I have the dollar.
It's fine.
I could have more than a dollar.
I could have 75 of them.
One more case.
I'm not going to listen to you guys.
What if your dollar is the dollar to surpass Metal Gear?
No deal.
14?
Okay.
We're going to go with 14, you guys.
Open the case.
We have the dollar.
There's no way we don't have the dollar.
Oh my gosh.
Here comes the offer.
Hello.
Okay.
I'll let him know.
Love you too.
Okay.
See you tonight.
The offer did go up.
Oh.
Or no deal.
He's rage quitting again.
Here's more money than what he's offering.
Okay.
I'll take it.
You guys, I'm not going to take it.
No deal.
The leave and the four.
Show me one dollar.
We still have $750,000 on the table.
We still have it.
I'm going to get rid of 24 because her hair is too yellow.
You guys, look.
Actually, she's very beautiful.
I'm not making fun of you, Christy.
Please don't have $750,000.
Open the case.
Guys?
It's a miracle.
Here comes the offer.
Hello.
Okay.
This guy is just like... he's about to... he's about to pounce on you.
Oh, my God.
If this was real life, I would be taking that.
Immediately, I would be taking that.
Oh, but it's not real life, you guys.
You guys.
You guys, I'm so curious.
What's in mine?
$1,000.
I missed a few of those.
Take the $50,000.
All in, baby.
He's literally... his head is on the...
Google the Monty Hall problem.
I do know it.
The Monty Hall problem.
Switching over... wait.
Switching over staying.
Mythbusters confirmed it.
Trust me when you want to switch.
So, we do want to switch.
Should we swap cases?
You guys, it's a lot of... swap cases?
But we have four.
Believe in four.
Ride the four.
Believe in your case.
I know.
No swap.
Always swap.
Look at them.
Oh, my gosh.
We're all bouncing.
Oh, my God.
What is Howie doing?
Oh.
You guys!
We should have swapped.
What's wrong with you?
What is this?
I got a donkey.
No deal, Mr. Banker.
Refuse a banker's offer of at least $300,000.
Why did they call me a donkey for that?
Oh, stubborn as a mule.
That's so funny.
Yeah, I got $1,000,000.
Just ignore... this is a comma.
$1,000,000.
Hey, $1,000,000 is a lot of money, okay?
So, it's fine.
It's fine.
$1,000,000.
Play again.
Mulligan.
Internally crying.
We should have switched.
I love how it was like, believe in the A.
Everyone's just like, you know that with the Monty Hall problem.
You should switch.
Do it.
Hello and welcome to Deal or No Deal.
I'm Howie Mandel.
Hi, Howie.
Ladies, please.
Oh, gosh.
Here they come.
Hi, Howie.
Here they come, guys.
Oh.
Oh, they're in gold this time.
Woo.
Hi, Howie.
I'm so terrified.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
Hi, Minto.
Why don't you guys ever greet me like that?
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Minto.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money placed there by a third party.
We don't know what's in what case, but we do know one case is holding...
One case?
...$1,000,000.
One
case.
One case.
Did you see that one Howie Mandel TikTok where he showed a dude's butthole and asked if it was COVID related?
Apparently lost sponsors because of it.
Oh, yes.
He showed a prolapsed anus.
Yes.
I do remember that.
I never saw the video.
Thank God.
But yes, Howie Mandel posted a prolapsed anus on TikTok.
I don't know why he did it.
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Oh.
I got...
Boy, I love that.
He what?
Yeah, that's what he did.
Actually, I don't even know what that means.
What is a prolapsed anus?
I just remember seeing people saying, don't look up Howie Mandel's prolapsed anus.
I doubt.
Like the movie?
Hi, Minto.
The enemy becomes an Audi.
What number should we pick everybody?
What number should we pick?
Should we pick the girl that looks like me?
Should we pick number nine who's looking off to the side?
I don't know where that...
Oh, she's smiling now.
Okay.
She noticed that we...
She broke the simulation for a second there.
Hi, Minto.
If I had a nickel for every time you talked about buttholes this week, I would have more money than what's in case 15.
You know what?
We're going with case 15 then.
How much is in case 15?
Let's see.
This
week, I don't think that many.
To love, to marry, in sickness and in health.
Let's start by opening up six cases.
Six cases, baby.
I'm going to pick one at random.
Eww.
Oh, it was number four.
Gayla!
Yay!
That could have been us, everybody.
That could have been us.
Gayla, our queen!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Five cases to open.
Good start, good start.
14.
Let's get the fours out of the way.
Correlapse is when an organ or bodily structure escapes the muscles meant to keep it contained.
It doesn't have to be near an orifice.
What?
We're off the table already!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We're killing it.
Snake's doing his happy dance.
Happy dance, happy dance.
Four cases.
All right, now 24.
Get the fours out of the way.
Christy.
Open the case.
Oh!
Christy, I'm sending you to jail for that.
Princess Gayla, my beloved.
Yikes.
That was a really high one.
That was pretty bad.
A shame case four has one million inside.
No, it doesn't.
I already opened it.
Still winnable.
Yeah, still winnable.
Number one.
Should we just go in order?
Minto case, one cent.
No, it's not!
Open the case.
Kathleen.
Okay!
25!
How many more do I have?
Oh, I have two more?
Two cases left open.
Case 10 will have under 1,000, I bet.
Okay, Keely, I'm going to believe you.
Case 10, case 10, case 10.
April, April, April, April.
Open the case.
That is not under 1,000.
That is exactly 1,000!
Not less!
Profit.
I think, Keely, you need to go get some lottery numbers today.
For real.
Bad.
Dang, Cole.
It was, it was rounded up.
It was probably like 999, you know.
Number 18.
17, 19.
17?
I saw two 17s.
If you are still reading this, there's still time.
Open the case.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, she's pumping the air.
We seem pretty satisfied with that.
17 was my pick for a case.
What?
I mean, that's a pretty, that's a good, that's a lot of money.
The man in this room would just run away.
There's one job, and it's a nasty job.
And his job is to get you out of here for as little as possible.
He's looking at the board.
Okay.
He's looking at you, and he wants to buy that case for as little as possible.
He's looking at the board?
He's looking at me?
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
He's going to call me and make you an offer right now.
He's got a nasty job.
Oh, he's nasty.
Oh, yeah.
Speaking nasty.
He's speaking nasty to Howie Mandel in his ear.
He's just like, yeah, you post that in as Howie Mandel.
Hello.
Yes.
Yeah, he said okay.
Okay.
He's speaking nasty words in his little ear.
He's whispering them.
He's just reading that.
There's a new offer.
No deal!
Or no deal?
No deal.
No deal, no deal.
Yeah, Howie Mandel!
No way.
He's just open.
Don't open?
Low offer too soon.
Yeah, I think it'd be silly.
Unless we've lost a million, you know?
Twelve is looking sus.
Sorry.
In a bad way or... wait, last time you guys said that, it was really bad.
12 was just like, I have one penny!
I hope no one chooses me!
Dirty, nasty banker.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I don't trust 19.
We go 20 now?
20...
Don't pick 21.
Not 13.
Okay.
Go with 11.
There's so many choices!
I don't know about you.
I'm feeling 22.
How are we splitting what's in your suitcase?
I mean, what if it's a penny, you know?
I
was not feeling 22.
Okay, three cases left.
Weird logarithm.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
Thank you.
You guys!
Okay, we can still get 700.
Maybe we will take what the banker deals us.
If it's higher than 100,000.
Open the case.
75!
Thanks, Avery.
It's so...
Berserk, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Two cases left open.
Don't give the banker the satisfaction.
Maybe, yeah, if you open it, you don't get the money.
Basically, the rules of the game is you pick one of these and then you eliminate the rest in hopes that your case has the $1 million.
Hi, Yao.
11?
Okay.
They wouldn't put two big ones next to each other.
Yeah, surely.
Woo-hoo!
$5!
One case.
Yeah, you want to get low numbers.
Leggy kick too.
19.
I like 19.
I think she's really cute.
I like her hair color a lot.
Please, open the case.
Jolene... $10!
Nice!
If
only we... this would be like the perfect game if we hadn't gotten rid of the 1 million so early.
Oh gosh.
Our offer's gonna be so low.
Hello.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
See you tonight, Banker.
Ugh.
No way.
Banker, you trying to put a fast one on me, huh?
No deal.
No way that we're gonna take that.
I know we lost the 1 million, but there's so many more opportunities to get higher than that amount.
Like, come on.
$64,000.
$64,000?
Four cases.
Siege, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Ah, you guys.
You guys, what do I pick?
Seven?
Seven.
Your...
Open the case.
Thank you, Dr. Ashton.
Okay.
You know they don't need that long to tell the price over the phone.
The Banker's flirting with how he ever calls.
Okay.
Three cases left, though.
Three cases left.
Don't say, ouch.
It's okay.
It's not that bad.
We're pleased.
We're okay.
25.
Two.
Lots of twos.
You.
Sydney.
Open the case.
Oh.
That one is not so great.
That's...
Looking at my misery.
Stop clapping.
Two cases left over.
Oh.
I think I will go with 26.
You.
Elizabeth.
Open the case.
Okay.
Nice.
16 has a 500K.
I don't...
How are you so sure?
Are you from the future?
One case.
I want to ask if you got my friend's gift, which was the mint box from Off-Kai.
I haven't actually gotten the packages from Off-Kai yet.
They just shipped them, like, yesterday or the day before.
It was there when he heard you wanted it and he freaked out super hard.
Did you get my fan art letter postcard?
No.
Oh.
From Off-Kai?
I'll check once...
Oh.
The stuff comes.
Okay.
Five?
Do not pick five.
13.
21's looking at me funny.
No.
She's looking away.
She heard you.
Maybe we go with 13.
13.
Amber.
Open the case.
What happened to the audience over there?
Oh.
No.
Nice.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
Here comes the offer.
He sounds so excited.
He's like, here comes the offer.
Hello.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah.
That's what you're gonna do, Baker?
Okay.
Alright.
What is it?
Just over...
Just over a hundred thousand.
I don't know, guys.
Six figures looking pretty tasty.
I know.
I think...
I think I'm gonna do one more.
I'm gonna do no deal and I'm gonna do for one more.
No deal!
We gonna see if we can get it up higher.
We can get it up higher, I think.
We can get it up higher.
Okay.
So the case is left open.
I believe.
I believe, I believe, I believe, I believe, I believe.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
Let's see.
Are we in the chat?
21?
Okay, 21.
All or nothing, Karen.
Open the case.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
5,000!
I wish it was one of the hundreds, but that's okay.
Okay.
Not bad.
There's also the 50, so...
Two cases left open.
A lot of people saying five, some people saying six.
Some people told me don't pick five.
I'm gonna go with six.
I'm superstitious.
If you say don't open one, I'm scared to open it.
There you go.
Oh, we're dancing.
Never mind, it's good.
I think...
I don't understand these people.
These are such high numbers.
I don't understand.
They're such high numbers.
Pick five, my lord.
Nine?
Maybe we'll go with five afterwards.
Please, open the case.
Please.
This is what you're doing.
You have $50.
What do you think is gonna happen?
I'm holding you to that.
Right.
Roblox.
Oof.
Okay.
A new offer?
Come on, Banker.
Banker.
No deal.
Deal?
I won't do it, Banker.
I won't do it.
Are you sure you didn't go to a weird cult meeting with the soulless people watching?
I swear.
They're ready to suck my soul.
Two cases left open.
Two cases.
This man thinks of us as a fool.
Yeah.
Thinks us as a fool.
Five or 23?
I like how we're glowing.
Gonna go with 23.
Please.
Open the case.
This is your fault!
You guys told me 23!
One case.
Okay, I'm gonna go with five.
At this point, risk it for the biscuit.
Open the case.
There you go.
Why are they clapping?
Because they feel sorry for him.
They feel sorry for me.
If I have the fifty dollars...
What do you think is gonna happen?
I'll go donate fifty dollars to somebody.
I'll go donate fifty dollars to...
to a random VTuber.
Really?
What do you mean by that?
The offer did go.
117!
Deal or no deal?
So we still have 750, 200, 100.
50, 400, 750.
It's basically 50-50 to get more money.
Well, I mean 100k is not more, but it's like close enough, maybe.
One third to do better.
It's so tempting to just say no deal every time.
Suddenly case 15 just manifested 50 dollars.
One more case.
It's a horror film.
It's a horror.
This game is a horror game.
Truly.
16.
The one that looks like Minto.
Melanie.
Melanie Minto.
You guys, I think we're walking out pretty...
Not so good.
What do you think's gonna happen?
I think we're walking out not so good.
Hello.
Okay.
Really?
Right.
It's gonna go down.
It's gonna go down for sure.
The offer went down.
Yeah.
Oh, no, no, no.
No.
No deal.
I wonder if the audience has any different expressions.
Eight.
Eight?
Okay, I'm seeing everybody say eight.
I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you guys so much.
I trusted you guys.
I
can't even afford shoes at this rate.
I can't afford anything.
What do you think's gonna happen?
It's gonna go down, Howie.
Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
Hello.
What do you mean what do you think is gonna happen?
Okay.
The audience is smiling while I'm suffering.
Look at them.
New offer?
Wait, did that go up?
Or am I crazy?
Deal or no deal?
No.
Okay, it went down.
No deal.
At this rate...
At this rate, we're just gonna...
We're just gonna...
The odds are really against us.
But you know...
The odds are extremely against us.
One case.
But you know...
I'm gonna do 25.
750 or bust, baby.
Open the case.
Okay.
There's hope.
A new hope.
What do you think's gonna happen?
Howie, Howie, Howie.
I'm not writing this fan.
He's like wanting me to continue.
Okay.
He's mauling again.
He's like, please.
Just take the money.
You guys.
Deal or no deal?
I think I need to take this.
I think I need to take it.
But for the content.
It's such a good deal.
But I'm not a smart person.
I believe in case 15.
One case.
18 or 20, you guys.
Guys.
18?
20?
I'm just gonna close my eyes and pick one.
Oh, wait.
I can't, I can't see.
I'm trying to feel it with my...
20.
Open the case.
Guys.
What do we do?
It's going to go up.
It's going to go way up.
Oh my God.
Swap.
It went up.
Only an idiot would not take this.
Oh my God.
Only an idiot would not take this!
Only an idiot!
But I'm not gonna take it.
We can get the $700!
We can get the
$700!
Oh my god, Nano, your case had $750,000!
We went from $750,000 to $750,000!
What
happened to believing in Case 15?
But you guys told me to switch!
You're in your bed.
My stomach hurts!
Oh god, I think I'm gonna throw up!
Oh my god!
No!
I'm never gambling ever in my life!
I'm never gambling!
Wait, what did Nano say earlier too?
It was just like...
Wasn't it like, I'll pay you more than what's in the case or something?
Hey, pay up buddy!
You were the luckiest person for 24 rounds to throw it all the way on the 25th.
I can't.
I can't right now.
1,800 gambler.
It's about the... It's a bit about the Monty Hall problem.
It only applies if the dealer chooses the door that opens.
So in this, it's just 50-50.
Oh my god.
We got this, guys.
We got this.
Don't do this!
Thank you for the...
You had a really good pick, man.
You picked a really good game.
Oh my god.
Betting $2 off Minto.
We were ever broke.
So far, we have made $1,700.
They
like, match my ribbons.
They match my ribbons!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for the pick.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh my god.
Ooh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
The way they all don't blink.
Nobody in this game blinks.
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money placed there by a third party.
Oh, Howie blinked.
We don't know what's in what case.
But we do know one case is holding...
$1,000,000.
I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna get the million.
All the way down to one penny.
That's not gonna be me.
Pick a case.
I love that you went from wanting to walk away to shouting, no deal.
I'm all in, baby.
To realizing you made it interesting.
Like, come in and die.
We did it.
13?
16 again?
We never picked 16 to begin with.
Bro, you're looking like Chibi Titans.
I don't know about you.
No, they wouldn't put 20.
They wouldn't put the million in 22 again.
Forever 17.
Forever 17!
I could only afford to pay for one blinking animation.
Ooh, Veronica.
To love and to hold, to cherish.
I'm not gonna sell it.
Not this... I'm not gonna sell it.
God.
You know what comes after 17?
Never 18.
11?
Let's go 11.
You.
Abby.
Open the case.
How about 17 will be the one million case?
5000?
Okay, nice, nice.
Never go to Vegas, please.
Not real money.
It's fine.
Right.
You have to open up five more cases.
Five more cases.
Five more cases, okay.
I'm just gonna guess.
I'm gonna randomly pick one.
Wait.
Okay, hold on.
I gotta land on one.
Where'd my mouse go?
Okay, here.
Ha!
Seven!
Open the case.
We're happy.
We're cheering.
Four more cases.
It could be worse.
Yeah, let's go with, let's go with Gala.
Yeah, wrong side of the board.
Come on, Gala.
Open the case.
Gala, Gala, Gala.
Yeah!
Oh, she's so cute.
I love when Snake dances.
Take the first deal offered.
It's gonna be so low.
Let's do... number six.
Hannah.
Bad.
This is just bad, you guys.
This is just bad.
This is not a good run.
We might just take the...
I don't know about you.
Wait, I clicked 22, right?
22!
21!
Please, open the case.
It's irrelevant.
You have the one million.
Okay.
One case.
Time to avoid 22.
Yeah, God just told me not to pick it.
Okay.
First number I see...
17 has the million.
Nine.
I saw nine.
You!
Emily!
Open the case.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
We're gonna do a little dance.
Yippee!
There's a man in this room with just one job.
One job?
A nasty job.
His job is to get you out of here for as little as possible.
Nasty, nasty man up there.
He's looking at the board.
He's looking at you and he wants to buy that case for as little as possible.
Why are you some nasty banker?
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
He's gonna call me and make you an offer right now.
IRL Eeyore.
Thank you for the birthday gift.
Thank you so much.
What do you think is gonna happen?
Thank you.
Dirty, nasty man.
He whispers dirty, nasty things in my ear.
Okay.
Dirty numbers, percentages.
Fractions.
The new offer?
Oh!
I kind of want to take it.
Deal or no deal?
But it's so bad.
What should we do, guys?
No deal.
We'll go with $100,000 deal.
There's always the what if that makes me want to just push forward.
You know what I'm saying?
There's always the what if.
That's chump change.
You're so right.
I doubt it.
Matthew, don't doubt me.
$25,000.
Lolzy, it better not be $1,000,000 or else I'm gonna be...
Ah!
Lolzy.
Lolzy, why?
Four cases.
Banned.
It was not a million.
That's true.
Pick number three, my lord.
I'm gonna go with two.
Open the case.
Ah!
$75,000.
Man, he said we'll go with $1,000,000.
Yeah, but we've gotten as high as $400,000.
We can do it again.
We can get $400,000.
Please pick case three.
Okay.
I'm stealing all your life force.
Lolzy, thanks.
We'll go to membership.
Open the case.
Ah!
Yeah.
Wow.
The right side is looking awful.
Oh, my gosh.
It's really dark.
Two cases left over.
It's looking not so great for us, you guys.
That's what every gambler addict says.
That's why I'm not in Vegas, baby.
I'm feeling 20 in my jellies.
10.
15.
8 for $500 loss.
Statistics don't lie.
Go 15.
The math works.
Okay, James Cameron.
I'm gonna go with $100,000.
I'm believing in you.
15.
Please, open the case.
One more case.
Still got the million.
13?
I have a bad feeling about this.
Open the case.
Oh, my gosh.
Nevermind!
We still have like all the lowest numbers though.
Every single one of them.
James Cameron, how could you do that to me?
James Cameron!
What do you think is going to happen?
That would have changed my afterlife.
500,000 times.
Why did you do that to me?
Right.
I went down!
Our sad face.
No deal!
Don't let it go down!
What an insulting offer.
I know, right?
We still have the 1 million on the board.
I wonder how like...
Like statistically how easy it is to get like super low numbers.
Like what is the lowest offer he can give us, I wonder.
Let's see.
18?
I'm not feeling 22.
Jimmy, you take that back.
Open the case.
22 is...
Nice, nice, nice, nice!
100, 100, 100!
From what I remember, about 40 cents.
No way.
26, please.
Okay, I see two people saying 26.
Skeptical Panda!
Welcome back, thank you.
Open the case.
26, 26!
There you go.
Yeah!
I can't even look anymore.
I can't even look.
This is stressing me out.
Do all the girls also have the same eye color?
Are they literally just copied and pasted?
Two cases left open.
I think they all have the same eye color.
Sailor Moon for a turtle!
Thanks for doing that.
Thank you.
Guys,
what do I do?
Number one?
Oh God, I don't know about this one.
I don't know about this one.
I'm not feeling it.
Open the case.
I told you all.
One more case.
I told you all, not number one.
I told you!
Let's go for a low score.
You know what?
Yeah, we still have all the lowest numbers.
Let's go for a super-duper low score.
Okay, then what we're gonna do is go with 22.
22!
Since I was protected from picking that one before.
Open the case.
700.
750!
What do you think's gonna happen?
I don't know.
It's gonna go down.
It's gonna go even more down.
Okay.
750 for what?
Versus one cent for the...
How are you feeling it now, Mr. Krabs?
A new offer?
Oh, come on!
Wait, what was the previous one?
Deal or no deal?
It went up a little tiny.
Like $2,000 it went up.
Like $2,000.
Less than.
$1,900.
A contestant on a UK show was once offered zero pounds and 12 eggs.
What?
You have 750 again.
Don't swap.
No deal!
Like they were rubbing our hands.
We're just like, I don't know, man.
Oh!
We're thinking.
I know our odds are looking really bad, but come on!
Three cases left open.
What should I pick?
Trust me this time.
Pick eight.
Okay.
We're trusting Lozi one more time.
Open the case.
Audra.
Oh!
There's our cent!
It's not enough money for her kids in the home.
Cute.
Are you okay?
One cent!
Two cases left open.
We finally got one of the low numbers out.
No!
Okay.
Yeah.
Now we won't get the lowest offer.
10?
Let's go with 10.
I won't get the lowest offer.
I want to get the million.
Open the case.
500.
I mean, obviously, we're not getting it this game, but I want the million.
It will happen.
One more case.
One more.
12?
Okay.
19?
Oh, yeah.
I like her.
I can't remember her name.
Jan.
Open the case.
10!
Okay.
Surely, our offer will go up now.
A little, maybe.
I think.
Everybody.
What do you think is going to happen?
Bye.
Thanks for the raid.
We're playing Deal or No Deal, and it's really intense.
Right.
It's like crazy.
Right back.
Thanks for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
It went up.
Oh, come on.
This banker.
I'm like...
Literally, I'm going to attack you.
I'm going to find him.
He's molding.
Why are you molding back there?
Murphy, thanks for the gift.
Why are you molding in here?
You're acting like this is...
I mean, it is a lot of money, but like, comparatively speaking, it's not that much.
Pyrobug, thanks for the gift.
Tobias, thanks for the gift.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
That is the end of the game.
That is a lot of money.
I know, but he has offered me $400,000 before.
Two cases left open.
Okay, guys.
Leah, if you're still here, do you want to pick my next case?
If you're still here, Leah.
If not, I see people saying 5S.
Why?
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
This guy is heavy breathing in my ear.
Oh, my God.
Okay, number 5.
I'm shaking.
I'm shaking, you guys.
I was shaking.
Okay.
We'll go with 5.
I redeemed myself.
Yes, you did.
Thank you.
Open your case.
Joey, thank you for the gift.
Thank you for the gift.
Don't clap.
Stop clapping.
Don't say nice.
Okay.
23 is a low one, trust.
23.
Yeah.
23, Teresa.
Come on, come on.
Guys, I think it's Jover.
Dollar, I think we owe him a dollar.
Here comes the offer.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The offer is going down.
Come on!
We could have the 750.
No deal.
No deal!
I trust, I trust, I trust, I trust, I trust.
We'll get an achievement for winning more than $700,000.
One case.
Take these deals seriously, game.
I know, right?
One case.
We stand, case 17.
Right?
20.
12.
16.
Let's go with 16.
Miss Mint Phantom.
Melanie Phantom.
There you go.
Oh!
All right, we have another $700,000.
I think we have the dollars.
Look at us, with our hands on our hips.
Okay.
Hello.
Yeah.
Right.
He's like make him take this deal.
Oh!
What's so frustrating about it is it's always when it comes down to like the final five that he makes like a good offer, a decent offer, you know?
One more.
Let's go!
One more!
I'm a Catholic!
I can't stop!
I can't stop this.
One more!
Okay.
One more case.
Twenty has one dollar?
Trust?
Fourteen is so lonely.
Yeah, because she has the 750k.
Open your case.
So average of a number to get rid of.
It's not bad.
It's not good though.
It's just kind of, you know...
What do you think is going to happen?
I don't know actually, Howie.
Hello.
Okay.
I'm not so invested in your relationship with the banker.
Oh, okay.
I am just... Oh, okay.
You sounded so disappointed.
It went up.
Okay.
Deal or no deal?
Oh my God, you guys.
Only an idiot wouldn't take this.
One more?
Should we do one more?
We always have the 750k left.
It's crazy.
You got one more in you.
One more!
Gamble!
He's molding.
Fourteen?
I think fourteen is not a good one.
I think I'm going to go with twelve.
Twelve.
Open your case.
Oh my God, the offer is going to be insane, you guys.
What do
you think is going to happen?
I think we have a dollar, Howie.
I think we have a dollar in my seventeen case.
Hello.
Okay.
The banker is molding.
A new offer?
What?
I'm sorry, what?
It didn't even go up.
I thought it was going to go up to like four hundred thousand.
Wait, it went down.
Why did the offer go down?
Excuse me?
No deal, Mr. Banker.
Why did it go down?
Yeah, it went lower by like a couple thousand.
Insult.
They know.
No deal.
It's because I have a dollar, isn't it?
One case.
Yeah.
You guys, you guys, you guys, you guys.
Please, open the case.
What
do you think is going to happen?
Okay.
We have a dollar.
We have one dollar.
The offer went down.
Oh my God.
It went down so much.
Poor Snake looks so sad.
Deal or no deal.
No, I'm taking home my dollar, man.
I'm taking that home with pride.
A dollar with pride.
We're such an idiot.
Snake is so dumb.
One dollar and a dream, baby.
You want to switch cases?
No swap.
Give me my dollar.
Here it comes.
What?
We didn't even get the dollar.
I'm not...
Doomed if you do, doomed if you don't.
This sucks so much.
Oh my God.
Another $750.
A dollar and a dream.
This somehow feels like a bigger L than if you...
I know I wanted the dollar.
Here's more money than you want in the game.
I'm never going to Vegas.
It's the desire sensor.
So true.
I think you guys are all the dollars.
You might be disappointment.
You might be a disappointment, but you're our disappointment.
Gosh.
I can't believe it.
This chat isn't even worth one dollar.
Oh man.
Okay, this time.
One million.
If we don't get the million...
We're taking the bankers deal.
Deal or no deal.
I'm Howard Mandel.
Real.
Ladies, please.
Oh.
Hi, Howie.
Oh my God.
Had Leah's viewers seen this yet?
This part is so scary.
Oh, they're in red now.
Oh God.
Here they come.
The la...
Les enfants terrines.
It's the genome soldiers.
Hi, Howie.
It's a great gambler.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, I love that.
That's one.
Thank you for the thought.
It's a thank you.
Hi.
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money placed there by a third party.
We don't know what...
Do you think he recorded these for the game or they took them from the TV show?
One million dollars.
I like the red dresses though.
Like the person that's breathing.
Pick a case.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know how to pick.
Hi, Minto.
Case three.
Sixteen.
Thirteen.
Thirteen is the million.
I'm very sure about that.
One...
Case number one had the one million last time.
So I don't think it's this time again.
You know?
Case eight.
Seems kind of safe, right?
Eight?
I think we're going to go with nine.
I think I'm feeling nine.
Yippee.
Soulless people jumping in the audience.
Nice.
That's your case to keep, to take home.
To love, to cherish.
To spend, do whatever you want, unless you should decide to sell it.
I won't.
Let's find out if you got a million dollars in there.
You ready?
There is one million dollars in there, Howie.
Let's start by opening up six cases.
I'm going to pick number 12.
Oh, there's a bug.
There's a bug.
Open the case.
No.
Oh, okay.
We're safe.
Back up.
Okay.
The bug saved us.
You have to open up five more cases.
There's a bug in here, though.
Oh my God.
Go away.
Okay.
Five more cases?
What do you guys think?
A hundred bucks down, baby.
Oh, welcome back.
Thank you, Calvin.
Five?
Okay, five.
Come here.
Open up.
What if I just go in order?
What if I count down from 26 and just go down?
Whoever... two people that said five.
What were you thinking?
50!
It's not bad.
Do it.
All right, next we're gonna count down.
We're gonna count down... 25.
Open the case.
Come on, Alexis.
You were doing so well.
It's safe to pick four and six because five is a big number.
I don't think that's how that works, but we can test it out.
Let's do four.
Let's pick Gayla.
And then we'll do six.
Open the case.
One penny.
Gayla, our girl!
We almost picked that case.
Also, is Howie supposed to be blonde?
Because his eyebrows are blonde, but his goatee is like brown.
One case.
But he is bald.
So, I don't know what to believe.
Does he dye his goatee, or does he bleach his eyebrows?
I don't know.
All right, six.
Hannah.
Open the case.
Hannah has always done me dirty, though.
I'm telling you!
She looks so apologetic in the background.
There's a man in this room with just one job.
A nasty job?
Oh, it is a nasty job.
His job is to get you out of here for as little as possible.
Shaves his head?
Seriously?
Hair and beard colors can be naturally different.
Really?
He's going to call me and make you an offer right now.
It's going to be a really bad offer.
It's going to be such a bad offer.
Joy, thank you for the 50.
Enjoy your Doom 64.
Do you plan to play Doom Dark Ages?
I'd like to.
Once it comes out, yeah.
Maybe.
So different from like the old school Doom stuff.
A new offer?
I don't know.
No.
As long as the million dollars...
Deal or no deal.
As long as the million dollars is still up for grabs, you guys, we're not taking the deal.
But once the million is gone, then maybe we should take the deal.
The million is still out there.
I don't know.
The odds are kind of against us right now.
But...
The odds are going to get worse and worse.
No, they're not.
Go with one.
If this has one million dollars in it...
I think I'm just gonna jump out this window.
Open the case.
Okay.
All right, Kathy.
Okay, Kathy.
I have a ginger beard and blonde hair, so I attest.
You have a beard?
My eyebrows are dirty, blonde, and my beard is jet black.
How did you grow that?
You have a beard?
Here we go.
I'm starting to think that in life, men can't deal.
Well, luckily, I'm in the afterlife.
We're shuffling.
We're shuffling dancing.
We're so happy.
Even though it's a lot of stuff from the right side of the board, but that's okay.
Okay, three cases left open.
Number three, baby.
Open the case.
Yeah!
It's
nice.
500k.
No.
Two cases.
All right, guys.
Two more cases.
What should we pick?
What should...
Twenty two has one million for sure.
No, I have one million.
23?
23.
Mine has mint-a-zillion dollars.
Open your case.
Yeah!
One
million still on the board.
One million still on the board.
One case.
Okay.
You guys...
What should we do?
Look at the scary people in the back.
Oh, God!
Howie!
He's, like, sniffing me.
Howie, you're too close.
What are you doing there, Howie?
Twelve?
Okay.
We'll go with twelve.
Twelve has to go.
Sarah.
Open the case.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Maybe we'll get an okay offer this time.
We got rid of some low ones.
Would love a...
Who wants to be a millionaire stream or collab sometime in the future?
Here comes the offer.
I would love to do that, too.
I actually owned that for the PlayStation when I was a kid.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
Okay.
Yeah.
Give it to me straight, Howie.
Am I...
Is it terminal?
What?
Oh, my God.
What the hell?
Me, blonde.
My brother, brunette.
And my father all have different hair colors.
Deal or no deal?
But all of our beards are red.
Why do you all have beards?
There's still...
Doshiyo.
Rock boss.
Thanks for the dollar.
Howie, I'm a wisp, not a mathematician.
No deal.
Oh, my God.
Are you a wisp?
Red beard.
Yeah.
Mint, where's your beard?
I'm working on it.
17?
I've seen several people say 17.
I think this one has the million.
This one has the million.
500.
Half a million.
50,000.
I'm about to say, It's the 50.
I'm a mint, not a mathematician.
I'm not a mint-metician.
I'm a mint... I'm a mint-metician!
Fourteen!
Yo!
Open the case.
Nice-o!
Two cases left.
What do you say, guys?
What do you say?
What.
Do.
We.
Say.
One dollar still on the table.
Really?
Oh my god, you're right.
Nineteen!
Yes, we love Jun Yun Min.
Yes.
Open the case.
Come on!
Open!
We're fine.
He's clapping.
Those are some aggressive claps.
He's like, we're okay.
We're okay.
Still one million on the board.
Seven!
Liner!
Oh, I accidentally skipped it.
I love when he does that.
Our deal is gonna be...
So bad!
The banker's gonna lowball us so much!
Okay.
The new offer...
Deal or no deal?
It could be better.
Or, I mean, it could be worse.
I think I'm gonna take it.
I think I'm gonna take it, you guys.
I want the million!
We'll do another game.
We got lowballed so much.
What was in our case?
Is it a dollar?
We're waiting.
I can't read it!
It's all two pixels!
What is this game having to do with me?
I'm never going on this TV show.
Your luck is so weird.
Welcome to my afterlife.
This is just the Minto way.
All right.
This is the One Million One million dollars!
This is it!
One million!
You're the best gambler ever.
Vegas loves me.
Vegas would truly love me.
But I was interested to see what happens if you choose the deal, you know.
Ladies, please.
The screen came from somewhere dark and...
Purple!
Will those hips don't not lie?
I've never seen anyone so bad.
I can't believe it.
Stop!
Why do you guys make me feel so bad about myself?
Here it is.
Hi, ladies.
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
They're like, haven't you been on this show like 50 times?
Our earnings don't even add up to like 100,000, I think.
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money placed there by third party.
Our earnings are so bad, you guys.
Like a total earnings.
One case is holding one million dollars.
Pick a case.
We're going to pick a case?
Hi, Minto.
Snake makes the ratings go wild.
Guy giving up before taking time to be here.
Lucky seven.
No, it just had the million.
So it won't have it again.
But maybe number eight will have it.
Wait, didn't we?
No, we picked nine before.
And seven had it.
It's got to be eight.
It's got to be the middle of the three of them.
Audra, I'm taking your box.
Get off the screen.
That's your case to keep, to take home, to spend, do whatever you want, unless you should decide to sell it.
No.
Maybe.
I don't know actually.
You ready?
Let's start by opening up six cases.
Okay.
Let's start.
I should have picked number six.
Six always...
You know what?
I'm going to start with six because six always has a high number.
If it has one million, I'm literally giving up.
Hannah.
See, I'm telling you, it always has a high number.
You're making all of us who lost our Firefly 5050s feel better, so thanks for that, Minto.
You should go to Vegas with Matara and have you do all the killing for her.
Every time, six has such a high number.
Every time.
Hannah's out to get us, man.
Let's go with 19.
Okay.
Open the case.
$5.
Okay.
Perhaps you should have picked case six.
No, no, because that's not one million.
That's not one million.
But maybe we will pick it next time.
Okay.
Four cases.
Number 12.
I'm going to do it.
Maybe do it by rows, right?
Okay.
Open the case.
Open the case, Sarah.
The penny!
We're dancing, we're dancing, we're dancing, we're dancing, we're dancing, we're dancing.
Very nice.
Okay, three cases left open.
You guys.
26.
All right.
Fernando says 26.
Please, Elizabeth.
Open the case.
Elizabeth.
Two cases left open.
Two
cases left open.
Okay.
$5.
Two.
I'm so sorry.
Choo choo!
Okay.
We have one more I think, right?
One more case.
Eleven, baby!
Okay, let's go for eleven.
Open the case.
Oh my god.
We are so boned.
We are so boned!
Does he have a giant nasty job?
It's a nasty job!
I feel like I'm reliving the same day over and over and over again.
Banker right there.
Okay.
What?
I think I'm gonna get a shit offer, Howie, okay?
Hello.
Okay.
Howie, do you grow hair?
They had to animate...
They even put his neck folds on the back of his head.
They even put that on his model.
No deal.
Do I ever accept the deal?
Oh!
Just like Bill Murray, but you're not learning.
What are you talking about?
It's different every day!
Oh...
Leave Howie alone?
That guy...
posts butts on the internet, so...
Endless eight dollars.
Re-zero starting after life broke.
One for one dollar?
One for one dollar!
Yipper!
Four more cases.
Groundhog deal.
You know what?
Since we just got four hundred...
Sorry.
I will pick four.
Open the case, Gaila!
Yeah!
Nice.
Twenty-one?
Okay, we'll go for twenty-one next.
Okay, three cases left open.
I don't know about you.
But it's not twenty-two.
Beep.
Weep.
Open the case.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we're jiving.
We're grooving.
I hope I get a dollar.
I want one dollar.
Two cases left open.
One dollar, one dollar, one dollar.
One dollar.
One dollar, one dollar.
Take your luck.
I had a shotgun.
See what happens.
Care to try buckshot roulette?
I've actually been interested in trying that.
But I think I saw that it was a pretty short game, right?
Twenty-five?
Oh, I almost clicked twenty-four.
Twenty-five.
Open the case.
Come on, Alexis.
Wow.
Number fifteen.
One more case.
One million dollars.
This is it.
Open the case.
One dollar!
Okay.
It's good for a short stream.
What do you think is going to happen?
Oh gosh.
Hello.
Yeah.
Okay.
You nasty, nasty man.
You dirty...
Okay.
Oh!
Seventy-one.
But we still have one million on the board, everybody.
We still have one million on the board.
One million on the... I mean we have a lot of like ten and seventy-five.
How many is there?
Four, five, six, seven.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Oh wait!
We actually have eight on the right side and seven on the left side.
No deal.
The odds are in my favor!
With mince luck, backshot roulette.
Oh, not backshot.
Buckshot.
Sorry.
Isn't that something else?
A backshot?
Just get to six figures.
I'm trying!
Buckshot roulette will be short.
No, it won't.
I'm gonna go for seventeen.
Seventeen.
Yep.
Open the case.
Three hundred!
Very nice, very nice, very nice, very nice.
Yippee!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just ignore what I said earlier.
Guys, come on, I need help!
Come on, I need your opinions!
What do I choose?
Five.
Yep.
Open the case.
Ah!
Nine!
It's not great.
Nine?
Wait, didn't we pick?
No, we picked eight, right?
Okay, we'll do nine next.
Two cases left open.
Nine.
Nine!
Emily.
Emily!
Five hundred!
Okay.
One more.
Yeah, there's no way seven has the million this time.
You're so right.
You're right.
I can't press it.
I'm shaking too much.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Wait, the AI summary is about what?
Open the case.
We're pelvic thrusting now?
Was that the last one?
Yep.
Okay, here we go.
What's gonna happen?
Hello.
Okay.
It's funny because one of my friends was just like...
The new opera?
Was like, I think you might need to start thinking about an 18 plus tag.
Deal?
Or no?
On Twitter.
So, um, I think I'll probably add one.
I didn't know what an un-birther was!
Okay?
No deal!
No deal on this!
Okay, three cases left, though.
Okay.
What does this mean down here?
The little...
The little dot.
But also, he said like there's sometimes you can get like a million dollar...
Offer some...
Like minigame or something.
So...
Okay.
People have already started using mating press.
Why are you making up your own tags?
I haven't even put...
I haven't even told you what it is.
Oh, it's the player on the Wii!
Oh, it's the Wiimote.
You're right!
You're so right.
I thought it was part...
Can this game be multiplayer?
It doesn't seem very fair.
Okay.
Number 23.
Yeah.
Come on, guys.
We got this.
Open the case.
Ten!
Yeah!
Our offer's gonna shoot up, man!
Our offer's gonna shoot to the stars!
Yippee!
Okay.
Two cases left over.
Ten has ten dollars.
Trust for...
We just got rid of the ten dollars!
You can't say that, Akiyama!
You can't say that.
If possible.
We should do one of the custom games.
Yeah, I wanna try.
I wanna try.
But I really wanna win the million dollars.
Twenty?
Okay, let's do twenty.
A lot of people are saying twenty, but if it's bad...
I'm gonna be really sad, you guys.
I'm not even gonna... I'm not gonna look.
I'm not gonna look.
Yay!
Okay.
One case.
Oh my god, the bug is back.
It's like a little gnat in my room.
I hate summer because all the gnats come out.
Three?
I don't know, I feel like three is the one million.
Open the case.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
This is a really good run.
It is!
Our luck has turned around so much!
What do you think is gonna happen?
We're gonna get a super good deal.
The banker is molding up there.
Okay.
The offer did go up.
But we're not gonna deal.
Deal?
You guys, we still have five hundred, seven hundred fifty, and one million on the board.
Like, we are killing it right now.
No deal.
No deal!
Two cases left open.
Two cases.
We have seventy-five and two hundred.
A thousand, ten thousand.
A hundred thousand, five hundred, seven fifty, one million.
Why are your eyebrows so thick?
No, it's a headband.
It's Solid Snake.
Number ten.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Okay, ten thousand.
Okay, okay, okay.
Remember this game started so bad with the two hundred, three hundred, four hundred, but now we're like, okay.
I'm thinking eighteen.
Ten for ten K.
Open the case.
Oh,
we already have a call.
Here comes the offer.
Oh, Howie, I'm scared.
Hello.
Okay.
Yeah.
Talk dirty to me, banker.
Okay.
I mean nasty to me.
The offer went down.
Down?
No.
No deal.
I still have one million on the board, mister.
Deal?
No, I'm not even gonna let you finish your sentence.
No deal.
We gotta get rid of the seventy five and two hundred, though.
Alright, guys.
What do we pick?
Thirteen?
I started watching YouTubers with you and Matara.
Wow, thank you.
Now I am a henya simp, too.
We got this next deal.
Yeah.
I'm also a henya simp.
There's also fourteen.
I'm gonna go with thirteen.
Open the case.
The offer went up.
What do you think is gonna happen?
It's gonna go up.
The banker is so salty right now.
He's like, screaming.
Oh, he's not.
Actually, he's not so salty.
Not yet.
The offer did go.
It did?
We still haven't reached four hundred thousand, though.
No deal.
You can't make me.
Not with that million dollars still stuck up there on the board.
Okay, I'm gonna go with fourteen, then.
I'm gonna go with fourteen, you guys.
Open the case.
Guys?
What do you think is gonna happen?
Okay.
It went up.
Of course it did.
Oh, shoot.
I wanna take it so bad.
I wanna take the deal so bad.
Yeah, next move will make or break for real.
We still have the one million, though.
And I said as long as there's still one million on the board, it is no deal, baby!
No!
One more case.
Oh, my God.
Oh, guys.
My stomach is hurting from the stress of it all.
Twenty-two.
I don't know about you.
I'm scared of twenty-two.
But it wasn't one million.
It wasn't one million.
It went down, but it...
I love your streams.
Thank you, Marcus.
Thank you so much for a super chat.
What do you think is gonna happen?
Hello.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah.
The offer went down.
It went down quite a bit.
No deal.
I will take the L before I take the offer.
Nasty
banker.
One more case.
Oh, my God.
You guys.
My anxiety is so high right now.
I don't know.
Sixteen or twenty-four.
What do I do?
Oh, my God.
Sweet sixteen.
I'm scared.
Twenty-four.
Sixteen.
I can't look.
Open the case.
What do you think is going to happen?
Hello.
Okay.
What do I do?
The offer is going to be insane.
The offer did go.
The offer is going to...
Oh, my God.
It's actually insane.
No deal.
Oh, my God.
Did I actually pick the one million dollar case?
There's no way.
Did I pick the one million dollar case?
You guys.
You want to switch cases?
Oh, my God.
No swap.
We're doubling down.
I believe in case eight.
I believe.
Please.
It
was right there in front of me.
It was.
It was right there.
In front of me.
One.
It was the closest we'll ever get.
Hold on.
My YouTube just froze.
I can't read the chat.
Ah.
You guys.
One second.
Oh, my.
Hold on.
Because I am...
I have to change my screen a little bit around.
You guys we were so close to the one million dollar.
You guys we were so close.
So close!
It was right there.
It was my lucky number not to ruin for me.
Let's change the settings.
We got so close there.
We got actually so close that I'm like...
Oh my gosh.
That was like probably the best game I'll ever have ever.
I've never seen anyone so sad about winning 100k.
I know, but when it was that compared to 1 million!
We need to add a pity system to this game.
I thought they also said...
I feel like if the 1 million is on the board...
Oh wait!
Oh my bad.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, hold on.
Wait!
No, ladies!
I didn't want to do another game.
I wanted to change the settings.
Seeing your luck with money, I wanted to send you this pity super chat.
Thank you, Takedo.
Oh, green!
Oh my god, you can really see their cleavage this time.
Hi, how...
Hello, ladies.
Oh, I love them!
Please say hello to our next player.
Get me out of here.
Pick a case.
No!
Wait, how do I actually leave?
How do I leave?
There's... how do I...
Oh, here we go.
Okay, quit.
Quit.
I want to change the settings, guys.
Let's see.
Maybe custom game.
What kind of custom is it?
Special event.
Oh, include minigames.
Yes.
Million dollar mission.
Two!
Wait.
Set million dollar mission.
Choose the number of million dollar cases.
My
luck can't be that bad, right?
Higher top value.
Double dollar value.
Double or nothing.
Random.
Two players?
Uh-oh, we're going against the CPU, you guys.
I'm kind of scared.
Wait.
The CPU is probably going to win, right?
Cheating ghost, but they allowed me to!
How does this game have multiplayer?
I have no idea.
Hello and welcome to Deal or No Deal.
I'm Howie Mandel.
Hi, Howie Mandel.
Hi.
Today's special, special episode.
Ladies, please.
The board.
What color?
Just like my ribbon!
Yup.
I'll cheer for CPU.
Why do you hate me?
Hello, ladies.
Hi, Howie.
Oh, I love that.
Please say hello to our next player.
It's me.
And...
CPU?
What?
We got 26 lovely ladies holding 26 cases.
Wait, where's CPU?
Each of those cases is holding a random amount of money placed there by a third party.
We don't know what's in what case.
But we do know one case is holding one million dollars.
I thought he was going to say 13 cases.
I will go with whatever is in my case, you guys.
I am not... I will go with whatever is in my case, okay?
I basically have a 50-50 chance of...
I will... I will...
I will not back down.
If I lose the million, I lose the money.
I lose the million.
And we are going with number four, I think.
Maybe.
Actually, I don't know.
I counted at the math.
It's not Monty Hall.
It's actually 50-50.
So I might as well swap anyway.
Unless you lose it.
Yeah.
Actually, I'm going to make it random.
I'm going to close my eyes.
And if you close your eyes...
You will almost feel one million dollars.
Number 11.
Abby.
Bomb Abby.
That's your case to keep, to take home, to spend.
Do whatever you want.
Unless you should decide to sell it.
Let's find out if you got a million dollars in there.
Yeah, every time I swap, it's bad.
And every time I don't swap, it's bad.
All right.
We are going to start with number four.
Lucky number four.
Here we go, baby.
Open the case.
We are picking Galen now.
25.
Oh, we are grooving.
We are schmoving.
You guys, this is a true test of my luck.
Five cases to open.
Um, 13.
Lucky number 13.
Actually, I should go for six because they always screw me over.
Open the case.
400.
Okay.
So, we are going to pick Galen.
You guys, are we killin' it or what?
I think we're doing really awesome.
I don't understand what the game mode is though.
It seems the exact same.
Number 6 has 1 million in it.
I need you to get Howie Mandel the guest on StarHustle.
I don't think so.
What?!
You guys, how is this possible?
Okay, 3 cases left open.
Guys, how is this possible?
Okay, you pick the next one.
You pick the next one.
9?
I saw 9 first.
Like turtles.
You.
9.
Open the case.
Our first 1 million down!
2 cases left open.
Suspiciously, we're gonna go for number 1.
17?
Okay, we'll go with number 17 next.
Sorry.
No, turtles!
It's all good.
One more case.
Alright, 17.
Someone said.
Thank you for the pink though.
You didn't have to do that.
Here we go.
Here we go, Veronica!
Open your case.
It's okay.
We have 9 left, I think.
Oh, 10 left.
3 in a row.
Man in this room with just 1 job.
And it's a nasty job.
And his job is to get you out of here for as little as possible.
He's looking at the board.
He's looking at you.
And he wants to buy that case for as little as possible.
You guys, do you think I have a million in my case?
He's working it out.
That's the banker right there.
He's gonna call me and make you an offer right now.
Do you think I have 1 million in my case right now?
What do you think's gonna happen?
No!
Hello.
Okay.
Right.
Surely you can get 13 in a row.
The new offer.
Wowee!
This is the highest offer I think we'll ever get in the first time.
Deal or no deal?
No deal.
There's still a million on the board, obviously.
I have 1 cent.
If I have a single penny in my... in my... in my case, I will... I will go akasupa someone right now.
Actually, quick idea.
I would love to see Mint play as the banker.
That'd be so fun.
25.
Open your case.
Come on, Alexis.
It's okay.
It's fine.
Four more cases.
And I think I will cry if I actually lose this because this is just... just a testament of my life.
My afterlife.
My everything.
My entire being.
Open your case.
When I was alive.
Get out.
I'm talking
to you guys.
I think I'm gonna... I think I'm gonna...
Okay.
Three cases left.
Oh, God.
I think I'm worried, you guys.
I think I'm worried.
Oh, no.
Open the case.
This is the next level.
Two cases left open.
I
picked number 10, okay?
You guys are bad.
Open the case.
That wasn't me.
That was you guys.
One more.
My stomach hurts.
Please.
The
hierarchy for anti-gambling.
Oh, God.
My stomach hurts.
I don't know about you.
I'm feeling 22.
Please.
Open the case.
Oh.
We broke the streak.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
If it was another million, I don't know what I...
I'm still scared.
Our offer is gonna be such a dog shit, you guys.
Okay.
Oh, God.
The offer went down.
Of course it did.
But we still have a million on the board.
It's a deal.
I'm so sorry.
The best worst luck ever.
This is like...
If anyone is ever just like, man.
Mint is not very lucky.
Like, are you...
This is just a testament to my luck.
Okay.
I have negative luck stat.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna go with three.
Oh, just like you Michael.
Let's go.
All right.
Open the case.
Please open the case.
Oh, gosh.
Two hundred!
I just want to win with one milli.
We're sticking with our eleven now.
We're sticking with eleven.
I'm gonna go with two.
I know Min's trying to buy more Metal Gear merch.
He didn't win that milli.
Open the case.
It's okay.
There's still a couple left.
That's alright!
There's still five million left, no worries!
Two cases left over.
I'm gonna go with five.
Let's just knock out the entire first row.
Let's just take it out.
Camille, come on, Camille.
Open the case.
A hundred!
If we have a dollar...
Oh god.
Okay.
Okay, I know you guys are rooting for my daughter.
Downfall, but please.
I'm gonna go for twenty.
Open the case.
Three hundred!
Okay.
Our offer might even go up.
That wasn't so bad.
That wasn't...
We're rooting for CPU.
Where is that guy?
Here comes the offer.
What if he was in the audience, like, staring?
Hello.
Okay.
Yeah.
It went up.
Nice.
But I believe in number eleven.
Oh gosh.
Oh golly.
What do I do?
Oh, I don't know.
Doubt it.
Okay,
three cases left over.
Three cases left.
Good night and good luck, Minto.
Thanks, Jessie!
Okay.
Twenty-six.
Open the case.
The dollar is out, you guys.
The dollar is out!
Who would have thought it would be this hard to get one million?
Two cases left over.
I'm gonna get rid of the second row as well.
Open the case.
Five hundred.
Our deal is gonna go up.
Our deal is gonna go way up.
One case.
Number eight.
Okay.
One case.
Number eight.
Open the case.
Seventy-five.
I can't even imagine what our offer is going to be.
Okay.
Look has changed.
Our luck has changed, everybody.
Here comes the offer.
He's mauling?
He's raging?
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Right.
Yeah, right.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Ooh.
The offer did go.
Not even 400k?
Come on.
Not even 400k.
No deal.
That's ridiculous.
That's so ridiculous.
I think we're so stingy.
I know, right?
Imagine he offers you more than a million.
Let's go with 19.
Our girl, Janine, never lets us down.
Open the case.
Oh, God.
One more case.
Number 16.
Oh, Jesus.
Melanie.
Open the case.
750?
Guys, how is there still one cent on the board?
What do you think's gonna happen?
I don't know.
Hello.
Okay.
New offer?
New offer, yeah.
What?
It went down?
No way.
Wait, did it actually...
Deal or no deal?
No deal.
Why did it go down?
This banker is so stingy.
I know we lost one million, but, like, come on.
One more case.
I'm gonna do 18.
Open the case.
There you go.
Here
comes the offer.
A dollar versus a million.
I mean, not even a dollar.
It's a penny versus a million.
Hello.
Right.
Okay.
Really?
I cannot.
I can't with this.
Okay.
Line up.
No.
You guys.
This is...
Deal or no deal?
This is an insane deal.
This is insane.
Holy cow.
One kiss.
It sounds like you said one kiss.
What are you trying to say, Howie Mendo?
If I get to kiss one of these lovely ladies...
Oh, there's a spider on my wall.
Go away.
I hate summertime.
Oh, my gosh.
14.
Why
did you do that?
I don't know.
I mean, I...
It's not...
I was going to say a kiss.
It's not dead.
It's still alive.
Why did you do that?
I don't know.
I can't...
Oh, it's 100.
Why did you do that?
It's...
It's not dead.
Oh my god!
It's so insane!
You have... you're a 13 million dollar penny.
No deal.
This is the highest deal I think I'll ever see ever.
This is insane!
This is... what is happening?
Oh my god!
Open the case.
Busting.
Here we go with 23.
Open the case.
We lost the penny.
Play a mini game.
Okay.
What is this?
What?
This is awkward.
You only needed to cheat to barely win.
Each round, choose one of your remaining cases to be removed.
If you choose a money case, you'll continue playing.
If you choose an empty case, your game is over.
Each round you avoid the empty, you will earn even more money.
You may quit at any time in between rounds to keep your winnings.
Okay.
Ready?
Ready.
Push.
Your.
Luck.
Oh.
Me?
Five.
Ready.
Push.
Your.
Luck.
Ready.
Push.
Your.
Luck.
Ready.
Push.
Your.
Luck.
Four.
Ready.
Push.
Your.
Luck.
Oh, guys, it's 50-50.
What should I pick?
Pick six?
Lady,
luck be kind.
Win one million or more in a single game.
Let's go.
Or more?
A little bird told me.
Unlock criteria.
Oh, pick a case that contains at least one million as the first case of any game in any mode.
Achieve a bank total of $250,000 or more.
Achieve a bank total of $500,000 or more.
One million dollars or more.
Let's go.
Wait, what's our... What's our... I want to see what our awards are.
How many are we missing?
Oh, wow, there's a lot of them.
There's so many.
Wow.
Blackjack time?
Yeah, let's do blackjack.
I cannot believe it actually came down to one million.
I mean, it was like three one millions.
But it was one million versus one penny.
I can't believe that happened.
Ready, push, your luck.
One million.
Blackjack!
Versus the computer.
Oh, that's the most mint thing ever.
Hello and welcome to Blackjack.
What just happened?
Wait, what?
Oh, we're playing in the thousands.
Um...
Hit?
Oh, hit me!
Hit!
I
would have lost otherwise!
Wait, where's the double down?
Hit!
Ooh, hit.
Guys, have I won any money or...
Hit!
I think I'm done.
I think I'm done playing.
I think I'm done playing D.R.
No.
D.R.
Oh!
What is wrong with you?
Thank
you!
I think I'm just gonna go.
It's okay, Zero, because you're priceless.
You're too kind.
This was a lot of fun.
This was such a rollercoaster of emotions, wasn't it?
We had some real highs.
We had some real lows.
But in the end...
I had to cheat to win.
And even then, it was barely.
You have terrible luck.
You can't count cards.
You're addicted to gambling.
You pick cases poorly.
What do you mean?
It's just picking cases.
What else am I supposed to do?
How am I supposed to win?
When it comes to being lucky, she's cursed.
When it comes to being loved, she's cursed.
Okay, hold on.
Let me...
I'm gonna quit.
Oh gosh.
I wonder what the leaderboard looks like.
I need some more water.
Give me one second.
I'm gonna actually switch this over.
I need a break after that.
Today, I was so... It was funny because I was like...
I was like...
I was like... Since I did Outer Wilds yesterday, I'm doing...
I'm doing like a no-brain game today, so...
It's a good thing you're cute, Mint, because you're luck.
I was like, I'm doing a no-brain game today.
It'll be so easy.
I'm just so sad.
I'm just so... I'm just so sad.
Oh, God.
Oh, man.
Actually, yeah.
That was fun, guys.
Thank you.
My luck is either 100 or negative.
This was a lot of fun.
I might be showing my age, but I will always remember Howie Mandel is the voice of Bobby from Bobby's World.
What's Bobby's World?
Uh-oh.
You're showing your age, Viralyn.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I have no idea.
Apache Slot stream flashbacks.
Gambling is so fun.
As long as it's fake money.
For me, at least.
Right?
I'm actually going to raid somebody today.
I'm going to raid somebody today.
I think...
Hopefully, I can raid her.
We'll see.
Either 100 or negative.
It's more like 100 negative.
But Miori... Miori Celesto is playing...
She's playing Red Dead Redemption.
So let me see if I can raid her.
No, sorry.
She's not playing...
That's Calliope.
Sorry, it showed up on my like...
It showed up on my thing.
She's playing Metal Gear Solid.
Okay, I need to go sleep.
I need to go rest, I think.
Oh no, it's not showing up.
I don't know if I can raid her.
I don't think it will let me raid Calliope.
I don't imagine they have that turned on.
Shoot, I wonder if I can...
Maybe if I put in her URL.
Thanks for the stream and keep on gambling as long as it's fake.
Thank you.
Wait, did she finish or did she just start?
I can't tell.
Oh, it says loading.
I think she just started.
Hold on.
Let me see if I put in her URL.
If it will work.
It will work.
I'm always nervous about raiding people because I don't want them to be uncomfortable.
This is the most hype and pain in a few hours.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for joining me.
This was a grand old time.
It was so much fun.
Paste.
Yeah, it says I can't.
Okay, I'm just going to post the link to her stream then if you want to watch Meori play.
She just started it seems like.
So...
Meori playing MGS2.
You can go...
We'll just manual raid.
It's the sand.
It absolutely is the sand.
We'll just say that.
Okay, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys and have a good night.
Tomorrow is Tokyo Jungle.
Tokyo Jungle.
So I'm excited about that.
We'll see how our luck fares there instead.
What a blast this was.
Hopefully next time I do a game show stream like this.
Maybe we can make it a collab with like some other VTubers.
We'll see who's available.
Look!
Thanks for two months.
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
I think I'm going to go bed rot now because I'm just so sad.
You guys enjoy the rest of your evening.
Have a good night or day or whatever.
This is what I always say.
I'm unlucky so that you guys can be lucky, right?
I will absorb all your bad luck so that you guys can have all the luck in the world.
So that all the good things can happen to you guys.
I take the fall.
I take the fall for it.
I'm blessing your gacha pulls right now.
Which reminds me, I need to go try in Blue Archive because...
I got Bunny Ashina, but I want to get Bunny Karin and...
Who was the other one?
They were both uniques.
Neru!
Yeah, Bunny Neru.
Okay!
Atsuminto!
Bye guys!
Bye bye!
Oh, and don't forget if you want to go manually raid...
Also, who said...
Who said Blue Archive gacha pulling stream 1?
Wheel of Fortune or Friends would go hard.
I would love to do that.
Who said Wheel of Fortune...
I mean, not Wheel of Fortune.
Who said Blue Archive?
I'm just going to go to bed.
Good night!
Atsuminto!
Itterashai!
Bye bye!